- On this episode, I
talk about names of apps,
listicles, and why nobody took over
at Wine Library TV.
You keep asking questions.
I will continue to answer them.
Hey everybody, this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and you're watching episode 30 of
the #AskGaryVee Show.
Fun fact about the number 30,
when I turned 30, I
freaked the (beeps) out
and started Wine Library TV, and kind of
changed the course of my life.
I'm actually quite scared about 40.
- [Voiceover] Maurizio asks, "Hi Gary,
"what's your opinion on listicle sites?"
- If you haven't noticed,
back in San Francisco
for episode 30, excited about that.
Listicles.
You know, it's interesting.
I have a very different view on this than
a lot of my friends and contemporaries
because a lot of my
friends and contemporaries
are journalists or have loved growing up
reading the Wall Street
Journal or the New York Times
or the Post, or these kind of things.
I think there's way too
much romance in journalism,
and here's what I mean by that.
I'm a huge fan of it because BuzzFeed
and UpWorthy and companies of that nature,
and let's not forget the
USA Today really started
infographics and listicles
in its modern sense,
though listicles have been around
for 100 plus years.
The people that are exploiting listicles
and our worlds are being
overrun by 12 things
a cat did while it ate
food, everybody who's
complained about that needs to understand,
this is the same debate
we had about reality TV,
the same thing we had about the people
that didn't like game
shows during the daytime,
the same thing we are
about everything, meaning
there's a huge misunderstanding
of how these things work.
Here's my example, what do
I think about listicles?
As a business? 24 months ago, phenomenal.
You were going up in trend.
Right now, super strong.
24 months from now, solid.
48 months from now, hmm.
72 months from now, concerned.
See what happens is we get these trends,
they matter, people enjoy them, and then
marketers ruin it.
We love listicles 24
months ago as a big base,
then you had the cynics and the haters
that started a little bit earlier,
and now what you're seeing
is, you're starting to have
a conversation of like, is it too much?
Are we clicking as many?
And the reaction of the market
is always what dictates.
I love the customer.
I don't love anything else.
So as long as the customer is enjoying it
and they're clicking it, everyone says
the Kardashians are crap, but
million of people watch it.
These things are subjective.
Listicles are subjective.
My POV on it, my subjectiveness on it
is if people enjoy them, then
that's what it's going to be.
And so for now and the next 36 months,
I'm bullish on it as a business.
As far as a consumer, I
don't consume anything,
so it doesn't matter.
- [Voiceover] Gabriel
ponders, "Gary, in the age
"of social media, tweet, vine,
Instagram length limited,
"how does, should this affect a startup
"in choosing a name?"
- Gabriel, this is a great question.
I understand what you're saying, right,
Twitter, tweet, you know,
kind of the short form,
you know I actually think
it's an interesting question.
The reason I decided to choose it is,
a name is made.
Meaning, when everybody's sitting around,
I have friends who sit
around and think about
picking the name of the
startup for 900 years.
And I tell them, what did
Google mean to anybody?
What did Facebook mean to anybody
outside of people that were
in the Harvard community
that knew what the facebook was?
None of these words mean anything
until there's something, right?
People email me like, uh
I don't like my last name,
like you're emailing Gary Vaynerchuk.
I mean, Vaynerchuk sucks.
Let's call it what it is, right?
And so now a bunch of you are gonna leave
in the comments. No no
no, it's kind of unique,
it's good. I get it.
But it's only good because
I made something out of it.
And so, what does it mean?
It means nothing to me.
If you went with a long-winded startup,
you could get abbreviations.
I actually think that's a new trend.
Somebody's gonna come out with a company
called like Copperhound Thompson,
but everybody's gonna call it CHT, right?
And so like in a world where
we're short-forming everything,
people call me V-chuk
because they don't want to
say Vaynerchuk and that became
my slang last name to my
friends in high school
and so we will evolve our
name into our convenience
if it brings value.
So stop worrying about the name,
and start worrying about the product.
- [Voiceover] Noble Rot Society.
(background murmuring)
(laughter)
- Right?
- [Voiceover] I haven't
written any blog posts.
- I highly recommend it
if your name's available
or if you own your dot com,
to just do it under that.
- [Voiceover] I do too.
- Cool.
- [Voiceover] Noble Rot Society asks,
"Gary, when you left Wine Library
"to start VaynerMedia, was
it a conscious decision
"not to have someone take
over Wine Library TV?"
- This is a great question.
People have asked me this question a lot,
and I wanna interject some depth,
like last couple questions,
last couple episodes
with some of this kind of fun stuff.
And insight that I've never talked about.
You know, I don't know if
it was a conscious decision.
Nobody really raised their hand,
nobody wanted that spot.
It's kind of like my
speaking career right now,
knock on wood I'm doing so well,
the bad part is I always
have to speak last
because nobody wants to go next.
I don't think it was the
right or obvious choice
internally at Wine Library to jump on it,
Ian, Brandon, you know all
these great people internally
just didn't' wanna have
the kind of, you know,
not responsibility, look it
takes a certain personality
to put yourself out there.
We've talked about the past, my blog post
about this the other day did really well.
You can link that, Stunwin.
So it wasn't a conscious
choice, it was the right choice.
If that person existed in the building,
maybe it would have
continued in that manner,
but I think one thing that
I'm really focused on,
why I took this question to interweave it
to everybody else while answering it
is I think you have to assess.
Like you always have to assess.
And I think way too
many people come in with
what they want it to be, the notion of,
somebody will take over this show,
and then you're forcing someone
to sit in the hotseat, and then you really
lose the lustre of it.
Not to mention, I may want to jump back
in that seat one day.
(bell dings)
Question of the day.
Where do I want to, San Francisco,
I'm in San Francisco, I
should ask a San Francisco,
what is your favorite
thing about San Francisco?
And remember, you guys are
letting me down on this
'cause you're so focused
on answering questions.
I want critiques.
Now that you've had two of them,
give me the overall feel of
these five-minute episodes.
You keep asking questions!
Oh!
This is my opportunity to make
my Jets-Broncos prediction,
since my Chargers-Jets wasn't so good.
Let's go 41 to 13,
let's go 41 to 13 Broncos.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
Subscribe!
I need subscriptions because I can't push
this many right hook in
social, so subscribe!